first on CBS this morning we have a very  exciting announcement we are teaming up  with country music's biggest stars to  host a special night of at home  performances right here on CBS so you're  gonna see Blake Shelton and Gwen Stefani  they're just two of the many artists  featured though they are in Sunday's ACM  presents our country so two hours  special we'll have more big names like  Little Big Town Carrie Underwood and Tim  McGraw will also include of course a  tribute to country great Kenny Rogers  the ACM Awards as you may know we're  postponed due to the corona virus so  this will air in its place and the  coolest thing about it is all of these  guys shot it themselves on their own  phones at home